the establishment media's disdain for
the Trump administration is no secret
but recently one of their biggest
targets has been White House press
secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders case in point
this particularly personal broadside
from MSNBC's Mika Brzezinski those
briefings are useless well I usually
does not say anything that is truthful
and she does not intend to she's the one
protecting a president who does that
every day who watches TV every day and
tweets stupidity what she is doing is
helping damage this republic those are
just a nice thing she said joining us
now with reaction White House press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders who's
freezing out there Sarah great to see
you Merry Christmas how you doing it's
great great to be with you a little cold
but other than that we're doing great
Sarah we have big news to get to on tax
reform big big day but I have to say
I've been watching you now for months in
that briefing room with patience with
with an ability to deal with the craap
being thrown at you on a
minute-by-minute basis you have more
patience than I would ever have but then
you hear comments like that from another
female at female journalist how do you
process that that particular comment
which I found of all of them said lately
particularly objectionable look it helps
that I have three toddlers at home so
I'm pretty good at having a lot of
patience and sometimes dealing with the
things that you don't always want to
deal with but look this was a president
who was elected by the Forgotten men and
women of this country and a lot of
liberals have contempt for those people
whether they're men whether they're
women and they want to attack us I think
that it's a great reminder of why this
president was elected we're here to do a
job we're here to get big things done
that's what we're focused on and if they
want to focus on petty attacks that's
fine let them have at it while they're
doing that we're gonna get tax cuts
passed in this country we're gonna
continue to grow the economy continue to
create jobs two million new jobs since
this President came into office and I'm
a lot of those are going to women and
maybe we'll get to replace some of those
female journalists out there they don't
like us very much at some point the
bottom line is this is a president who's
focused on getting things done focus on
getting things done for the men and
women that frankly a lot of the liberal
elites in this country don't like have
contempt for and he's focused on
empowering women and he is doing that in
the way he puts people in place in his
administration and I think it's sad that
they're attacking a lot of us while
claiming to champion women's causes and
women's issues yeah I've been on the
receiving end of that but I wear it as a
badge of honor the more they're
attacking and the better off better a
better job I think you're doing let's
talk about this just your role because I
think a lot of Fox people watching now
Fox viewers they watch you out there
doing combat daily combat and I think to
themselves okay what if what if she's
talking to the president he says you
know go out there and say this but it's
not something you're comfortable with
you just I'm not talking about any
specific issue but would you say to him
boss that's not something that's not
something I'm comfortable saying but you
know maybe get someone else to go out
there and say that have you ever done
that look if there was ever a moment
that I wasn't comfortable doing
something I wouldn't do it that's a part
of who I am and this president's not
gonna ask me to do something I'm not
comfortable with if I get to a place I
can talk to him and come to a place
where we agree on what the talking
points and what the message is but
that's just not something I'm ever gonna
be part of and I don't think or expect
him to ever ask me to do anything that
I'm not going to be comfortable doing
look I believe in what the president's
doing I believe in the agenda I believe
in what we're fighting for and the way
that we're trying to spend every single
day making America a better place I
think we've done a lot in the first 11
months and I look forward to helping the
president push that message over the
next seven years 32% approval rating and
a recent poll I guess it was a Monmouth
poll other polls show the president in
30 sometimes he gets up to the high 30s
why do you think at least now he hasn't
gotten so far he hasn't gotten the
credit for the dreg he's done for the
the tax cut obviously everybody's going
to get in the new year
the judges on the on the federal
pellet court record pace for putting
judges on the courts why is the number
still so low and how do you get that
number up look I think a lot of the
times the reason the numbers might be
lower than they probably really are is
because people aren't getting all of the
facts they're not getting all of the
good news parts of the what's happening
in this administration what's happening
in this country and I think a lot of
people are gonna start to see this
impact when the tax cuts go through
that's going to happen right away
they'll see the bigger paychecks
starting as early as February I think
there are a lot of big things that
you're gonna see the changes in the
deregulation process you're gonna see
the impact of that even more than we
already are at the first part of next
year but I think one of the big problems
is that stuff doesn't get covered we're
so focused on talking about the negative
and trying to attack this president
trying to deal ajith amaizing that some
of the best over the time the biggest
things that are happening aren't being
covered
it's beyond over-the-top I mean it's 90%
coverage is bad nothing he could he
could come up with a cure for lung
cancer tomorrow and they'd say well why
didn't he do it a year ago I mean this
is where it is let's talk about daca
because that what I'm hearing from my
little sources on Capitol Hill is that
the president may move to do a quote
daca fix which would could be amnesty
for 800,000 people brought here as
minors but without that raise act
attached without getting rid of chain
migration without getting rid of the
Visa Lottery system without reducing the
legal immigration the wall all that
stuff people like Scott Taylor Virginia
they're obsessed with doing this doctor
before the end of the year don't you
think the base of this party Sarah will
go crazy if that's what the president
pushes through when we have so many
bigger priorities here look the
president's focused on making sure that
we have responsible immigration reform
we've been talking about a lot this week
ending chain migration including funding
for the border wall increasing interior
enforcement's there are a lot of things
that we're doing we've laid out the
principles the things that we want to
see and we want to make sure that that's
part of any package that moves forward
that's our position and that's what
we're focused on making sure happens is
complete and responsible immigration
reform so you won't do any clean
quote fix that some of these Republicans
want will you look as I just said we've
laid out what our priorities principles
are and then that's certainly not our
plan this is a president who has talked
about campaigned and won on doing big
things when it comes to immigration
specifically funding a border wall
greater interior enforcement's better
vetting and just again making sure that
we have a responsible immigration system
something we don't currently have and
something this president wants to make
sure we don't just tinker with it and
fix small parts of it but that we fix
all of it Sarah when the when the you
see a judicial nominee up there as
yesterday mr. Peterson I believe who was
nominated a DC District Court struggling
with some you know questions about
evidence and and procedure issues that
you know when you're a litigator does
that give the president pause about the
waste some of these lower court judges
are being picked and selected look I
haven't talked to him specifically about
that but what I do know is this is a
president who's focused on making sure
we have judges in place that understand
what their role is and that's not to
create law that's not to change laws but
it's to be actually focused on the
Constitution and and making sure that we
have judges in place that understand
their place that was a bad deal though
that was that that was a that was a
viral video nightmare I'm sorry but I
mean he's his judges have been great but
and he's I'm sure a nice person he's
good at the FEC but as a district court
judge speaking of someone who clerked on
the federal Kellet Court of Appeals that
was a that was a brutal love questioned
by a series of questions by Kennedy so I
hope Don McGann and the crowd say takes
a second look at some of the procedures
for the for the district court Sarah do
you make apple pie by the way because
I'm not a big fan of pecan but I if you
had my pecan pie I think I could change
your mind I think I may have even one
over April Ryan at least for a day or
two with that pecan pie yes no no no
first of all in Connecticut we call it
pecan that's how bad we are you know you
got you guys have the right
pronunciation down south sarah huckabee
sanders have a great christmas and thank
you so much for spending some time with
us tonight
Thanks Merry Christmas or